حسنًا، كنا في جنوب إسرائيل
صباح يوم السبت بالقرب من الحدود مع
غزة عندما شاهدنا أكثر من عشرين
رجلاً يجلسون أو راكعون على
الأرض الرطبة الباردة. جنود إسرائيليون يقفون للحراسة
بالقرب منهم، والآن نعلم أن هؤلاء الرجال
كانوا فلسطينيين اعتقلتهم
قوات الاحتلال.  الجيش الإسرائيلي داخل غزة وتم
إحضارهم إلى إسرائيل للاستجواب الآن، كان
هؤلاء الرجال معصوبي الأعين وكانوا حفاة
القدمين، وإذا نظرت إلى هذا الفيديو
يمكنك أن ترى أيديهم مقيدة خلف
ظهورهم وكل ما يرتدونه هو
هذه المآزر البيضاء التي يمكن التخلص
منها الآن.  من المهم أن تضع في اعتبارك أن درجة الحرارة
كانت حوالي 50 درجة فهرنهايت و10 درجات مئوية وكان الجو
ممطرًا للغاية عندما قمنا بتصوير هذا الفيديو ويبدو أن
الرجال في هذا الفيديو مرهقون
جسديًا، يمكنك رؤيتهم
يتمايلون حول رؤوسهم
ويتمايلون كما يبدو  لكي ينام
كان هناك رجل مستلقي على
الأرض قبل أن يأتي جندي إسرائيلي
لإيقاظه ودعمه. الآن
قال الجيش الإسرائيلي من جانبه، اقتبس من
الأفراد الذين ظهروا على الكاميرا أنهم
يشتبه في قيامهم بنشاط إرهابي
وتم اعتقالهم في غزة و  يتم نقلهم إلى
إسرائيل لإجراء مزيد من الاستجواب،
ويتم أخذ المشتبه بهم لمزيد من
الاستجواب داخل إسرائيل، ويتم إطلاق سراح الأفراد
الذين يتبين أنهم لا يشاركون في
الأنشطة الإرهابية
إلى غزة في أقرب وقت ممكن، كما
يعالج الجيش الإسرائيلي الآن
الحالة التي وجدنا فيها هؤلاء
الفلسطينيين  وقال المعتقلون إنهم
كانوا يرتدون هذه المآزر البيضاء
لأنه تم تجريدهم من ملابسهم
وتفتيشهم للتأكد من عدم
وجود أي أجهزة متفجرة
أو أسلحة عليهم ولا على ملابسهم، وقالوا إنهم
كانوا على وشك وضعهم في
حافلة ساخنة ونقلهم إلى  مركز احتجاز
حيث سيتم تزويدهم أه
بالملابس الفعلية أه الآن لم نتمكن من
التحقق بالضبط من المدة التي قضاها هؤلاء الرجال في
الخارج في البرد أه
لأن جندي إسرائيلي جاء إلينا
ووجهنا عندما رأى أننا
نصور  غادروا المبنى الآن
فيما يتعلق بهذا الادعاء الإسرائيلي
بأن هؤلاء الرجال يشتبه في قيامهم
بنشاط إرهابي، من المهم
ملاحظة أنه على الرغم من أن هذه هي المرة الأولى
التي نتمكن فيها فعليًا من
توثيق احتجاز هؤلاء
الرجال الفلسطينيين من غزة هناك بشكل مباشر  لقد تم
تداول الكثير من اللقطات من غزة
لرجال فلسطينيين محتجزين وفي
كثير من الحالات تبين أن هؤلاء الرجال في الواقع
مدنيون وقد تم رصدهم من قبل
أقاربهم أو أصدقائهم
كمدنيين وفي ديسمبر تحدثنا بالفعل
مع 10 رجال وفتيان فلسطينيين
الذين اعتقلهم
الجيش الإسرائيلي لمدة 5 أيام ثم أطلق سراحهم في نهاية المطاف
دون توجيه تهم إليهم، والآن يعاني هؤلاء الرجال
والصبية جميعهم من تورم معصمي بعضهم،
وبعضهم كدمات على معصميهم
بسبب تقييد أيديهم خلف
ظهورهم لمدة 5 أيام، الآن
الجيش الإسرائيلي  من جانبها تؤكد أنها
تعامل جميع هؤلاء المعتقلين
وفقاً للقانون الدولي. جيريمي
دايموند سي إن إن تل
أبيب